We've used the LS command or
application a few times already, and
we know that it's located within
the slash bin directory, but
how come we didn't have to type
the full path to this file to run it?
Why didn't we have to type /bin/ls?
Linux systems provide a nice little
short cut system within the dollar sign
path variable.
Let's take a look at that and
figure out how the operating
system saves us some typing.
If you type echo $PATH and you run that,
you're presented with a bunch of
paths separated by colon characters.
We see /usr/local/sbin:/usr/local/bin
and on and on and on.
These are actually the directories
Linux will progress through looking for
a binary when you just type
the name of it like ls.
When you type ls, the operating
system checks the first directory for
an executable file names ls.
If it's not there, it checks the next.
And on and on and
on until it gets here to /bin.
And it does find that file,
so it runs it.
If you ever find that your
commands aren't being found, or
things are just acting really crazy,
you might want to check this variable.
I've placed a link in the instructor
notes that will walk you through how to
edit this variable and
save it if need be.